- Hi, everyone, Sal
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our daily homeroom livestream.
For those of you who
don't know what this is
(laughs) or what Khan Academy is,
Khan Academy is a not-for-profit
with a mission of providing a free,
world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And over the last many years,
we've been building resources
from early learning all
the way through elementary,
middle, high school, early
college, math, science,
English language arts,
and we always imagine that
it would be used in conjunction
with normal, physical classrooms
or it could be used by
students outside of classrooms.
Maybe students in parts of the world
who might not have access to materials
or certain types of courses.
So we could've never
foreseen the situation
that the world is now in,
but as soon as we saw the
school closures happen
many weeks ago now,
it seems like a lifetime
ago, I know, for many of us,
we realized that it's our
duty as a not-for-profit
with this mission to step up.
And so, you can see here the resources
that we've been putting together
to essentially keep everyone learning.
And so, we've been doing
things like this livestream,
which is just a way for
us to stay connected
and answer any questions you might have.
But also, we've been
doing parent webinars,
teacher webinars, we've
been putting together
daily schedules for how you
could structure your day
or your children's day
or your student's day
if you're a teacher.
We just put out learning plans
so that folks can understand
how they can pace themselves
over the course of
the next six weeks to 20 weeks.
We ideally think most people
should leverage the summer
so that you don't have that learning loss
and you're able to go to next school year
with as much learning under
your belt as possible,
as prepared as possible.
So, that's the goal of this.
We bring on guests every now and then.
I do wanna give a special shout-out.
We are a not-for-profit.
We are funded through
philanthropic donations.
We were already running
at a deficit before this
and our deficit has increased
because now our load on
our servers, et cetera,
are up over two and a half
times what we normally see.
I wanna give a special
thanks to Bank of America,
AT&T, Fastly, Google.org, and Novartis,
who are companies that have stepped up
just in the last few
weeks in order to really
support our response to what's going on
with the school closures, and of course,
our long-time donors who
help Khan Academy exist,
but we do need more support.
Whether it's an individual
donor who's able to give
five, $10, all the way
up to a corporation,
everything helps and allows
us to support more folks,
especially folks who might not
otherwise be able to afford
or have access to resources like that.
So, today, we're going to just
do another ask me anything.
We have some exciting guests tomorrow.
We have a vice president from
the college board to answer.
I know there's a lot of
questions around the SAT
and implications for when
the testing dates are
and implications for college admissions,
so we're gonna have a
very robust conversation
about that tomorrow.
But for today, it'll
be more of me and Dan,
my colleague is gonna help support
just any questions y'all have.
And I know there was a ton
of questions from yesterday.
We can answer some of those,
but happy to take any
questions y'all have.
So let's see, I have this
one question I'm seeing is,
so from YouTube, Nikhil Govendar says,
Hi, Sal, I'm currently
working on a project
that requires you to build an app.
Could you please give me
any suggestions or ideas
on building an app?
Well, this is interesting, and actually,
if anyone else has suggestions or ideas
for Nikhil's app, feel free (laughs).
And Nikhil, whoever's
suggestion you take, you know,
you owe them a cut, and
if you leverage ours,
donate to Khan Academy. (laughs)
So, app ideas.
You know, it's funny,
I'm always intrigued.
People before, on previous livestreams,
have said, Sal, if you weren't
working on Khan Academy,
what other things would you wanna work on?
And I'm fascinated by anything
that can help make other people,
help people have richer lives
or maybe explore that
whole side of happiness
and I had thought about it.
As far as I'm aware, no one's
building it, maybe someone is,
a app that helps build relationships.
It could be relationships with friends,
it could be relationships with co-workers,
it could be relationships with a partner,
where you're able to
essentially rate how you feel
about that relationship
and then you can benchmark
your relationship
relative to other relationships
'cause you would have the data
on how other people are
feeling about the relationship.
So I think that could
be an interesting app
if you're in a corporation or at a school
to measure kind of team
health or sentiment.
You could imagine in kind
of a marriage setting,
you know, things that go on in marriages.
People normally, you know,
try to keep it behind closed doors,
but they don't know, you know.
Are we in the bottom quartile of marriages
or are we in the top
quartile of marriages?
Do we argue an average amount?
So I think there's
something interesting there.
It could be with parents and children.
You know, is this level of angst
that we're experiencing
normal or is it isn't?
But if every parent was rating it,
maybe there's something interesting there.
So, that's one idea.
It's kind of a fun idea
but I actually think
it could have legs behind it. (laughs)
I think there could be
interesting apps around
just understanding yourself better.
You've seen kind of these
personality type apps,
but I think things
could, there is research
and mental health research and things
about activities or things that you can do
that will improve your wellbeing.
I think there could be interesting apps
for folks to help each other either
with some type of volunteer work,
or help tutor each other.
So those are the types of spaces
that I'd be interested in
if I were making an app.
So, let's see.
From YouTube, Kate Grafe says
as a pre-service teacher,
I was wondering how to
implement collaborative learning
through remote learning,
and what does classroom
management look like
in this scenario?
It's a great question, Kate.
And the world is figuring it out,
and I won't claim to be the expert here.
I've actually worked
with a couple of teachers
in a couple of school districts trying
to figure it out myself.
I've tried to run a few sessions myself.
The only tips I could give you based
on my limited experience
here with running real,
live virtual sessions
are the more interaction
you can get, the better.
I think, as you can imagine,
that's always the best practice,
even if you're in person.
But especially if you're
on a Google Meet, or Skype,
or Zoom session, it's
that much more important
to pull out responses from
the people who are there.
Because if you don't do that,
it's essentially equivalent
to a video.
And then you might as well be a video.
So I would say try to
pick out as much responses
as possible, depending on
what platform you are using.
There are techniques,
you can mute everyone
so you don't get all of their
home noise and all of that.
And then you can call on people, say,
"Well, what do you think?"
I know that Zoom has gallery view,
which is a really nice way of seeing,
if you can fit everyone on one screen,
you can say, Okay, does
anyone have a question?
You know, how do you feel about this?
You can say, how many of
you support the proposition?
How many of you are against it?
And I think that type of interaction
really keeps the conversation going.
One thing that I do, I do this
on the weekend with friends,
where we try to talk about just, you know,
how do we become better people?
When I finish the sessions,
and I'm usually the moderator,
I go through all of the
tiles on Zoom and I make sure
that I get a response from everyone.
I'm just like, hey, everyone,
30 seconds, one minute,
what's your takeaway from today?
How are you going to try to be different
or observe things
differently over the course
of the next week?
So those are practices that
I've seen work reasonably well
in a Zoom or Google Meet type scenario.
- Sal, you mentioned yesterday
about kind of approaches
for kids who are either afraid of math
or are scared about tackling that subject.
We have a related question.
You talked about a process,
but we have a question
from YouTube from ShockBlastYT.
Hi Sal, what's your
opinion on growth mindset?
Yeah, a good question ShockBlast,
and for those of you who don't know,
growth mindset's this idea that you,
many times folks will
have a growth mindset
or a fixed mindset.
A fixed mindset is, you think
you either have the ability
or you don't.
Let's say in math, you
say I'm a math person,
I'm gifted in math.
Or I'm not gifted in math, I'm not.
That's a fixed mindset either way.
Whether you have a positive fixed mindset
or a negative fixed mindset.
A growth mindset doesn't
say I'm either good or bad
at something, a growth mindset would say,
well, I don't know how my capabilities,
the only way I'm able to push the envelope
is if I am willing to try things,
I'm willing to step
out of my comfort zone,
and I'm willing to fail
every now and then.
And when I fail, I don't just
try to run away from that,
I reflect on why I failed
and how I could do it better next time.
And then I can keep going.
And as you can imagine, research has shown
is that folks with growth mindsets,
there's a strong correlation
between growth mindsets
and people who are
successful in the field.
And you might think that, okay,
I could get how the under-confident,
fixed mindset people,
they're kind of psyching themselves out.
Oh, I'm not good at this
subject, I'll never be,
so they don't even try.
But even the confident, or even,
let's call it the
over-confident fixed mindsets
also don't do well.
So if you say, in your head you're like,
I am genetically a great math person.
What happens with a lot of those folks
is when they are faced with a challenge,
they don't want a data
point that might undermine
their self perception.
So they actually might not
tackle the hard problem.
Because it's like, well,
what if I get the hard problem wrong?
Or what if my friends
see that I can't do it?
Then that's gonna undermine
my self perception.
But then if you're not willing
to try that more difficult thing,
you're never going to grow,
and in the end you're
not going to do as well
as a person who said, I'm just
always going to try things,
and I'm gonna try to
tackle it and if I fail,
I'm gonna see how it goes.
And not only is there a strong correlation
between growth mindset
and success in life.
And I gotta say, that
everyone that I know in life
who have done well in a
domain has a growth mindset
about that domain.
But there's exercises or
things you can realize
to build your growth mindset.
When you realize that your
brain is like a muscle,
the more you use it the stronger it gets.
When you get questions
wrong and reflect on it,
that's actually some of the best ways
to form neural connections.
That actually helps you
build a growth mindset.
And so, the way it's
related to all the work
at Khan Academy, you know,
a lot of what we talk
about Khan Academy is the
notion of having as many shots
at goal as necessary when
you go practice exercises
on Khan Academy.
It's not like you just do five exercises
and you got a 80% and we move
you on to the next thing.
You can take that quiz, that unit test,
that course challenge,
that mastery challenge,
as many times as you want.
And our team has painstakingly
put many items there,
so you're unlikely to
get repeat questions.
So you can get as much
practice and you can go
from a 60%, 70%, 80%, to 100% percent.
And our view is the
notion of mastery learning
and growth mindset are hand in hand.
A fixed mindset world
is I got a C on a test,
I guess I'm just a C student,
I'll move on with my life.
While a growth mindset would say,
I got a C on a test, let me try again.
And that's essentially mastery learning.
Let me try to turn that
into an 85%, a 90%, a 95%.
So it's something we hold
very dear to Khan Academy,
and I also think it's a
very important mindset.
And I have to be frank, we
all have growth mindsets,
hopefully, in certain domains in our life
and in other domains of our life,
for better, for worse, we
probably develop fixed mindsets,
and it's good to be reflective
on where we do have those fixed mindsets,
and how we can deprogram
ourselves a little bit.
So let's see.
There's a question from Elliot H.
Elliot, it feels like we're
getting to know each other.
(laughs) You ask good questions.
You always refer to me as Dumbledore Sal,
which I find very flattering.
You emphasize breaks and not overloading,
yet you did just the opposite as a student
and a young man.
Is this do as I say, not as I do?
How much must one work to
be an innovator like you?
All right, that's good.
I like questions that point
out potential hypocrisy
on my part. (laughs)
And that's or at least
perceived hypocrisy.
So you're right on a certain level.
If I were to, at least
the narrative I have
of my own youth, is that when
I was in elementary school,
middle school, I was a decent student.
I essentially did, for the most part,
what I was asked to do.
And then even my freshman year
in high school I was a decent student.
But I wasn't the student who was really,
I guess you could say, gunning in a way.
But then in my sophomore year I started
to kind of wake up to the
realities of the world.
I said, well, you know,
if I wanna be a little bit
more ambitious, I have
to apply myself more.
It can't just be me kind of calling it in
and just doing what's necessary.
So that is, I did become
a little bit more serious.
And anyone who knows me back then
knows that I actually wasn't
that serious of a person.
I like to believe I'm kind
of, I have a playfulness
about things.
But I got serious about my life.
My mom was a single mother,
raised me and my sister.
She worked as a cashier
at my uncle's food store
at that time.
So she wasn't making a lot of money.
She was making around 16, $17,000 a year.
I was on free and reduced lunch.
So I had a little bit
of a fire in my belly
to say, hey, I wanna live
like some of my friends
whose parents were professionals,
and they had health
insurance, they had houses.
And so that was a little
bit of a fire in the belly.
And I do, so, through
the end of high school
and early college I did
always try to push myself.
And I will admit, sometimes
I kept adding, adding,
adding, and at points it got,
maybe I pushed a little bit too hard.
And I'm guilty of that today too.
Even with the work at Khan Academy.
If anything, it's not that,
now at Khan Academy I'm like,
oh, it looks all like it's all perfect,
I'll just take a break.
There's something about
the further you go,
there's a little process in your brain
that says, Sal, you can't relax now.
Look at how much there is to do.
And so you keep layering more and more.
But then you also start to appreciate
if you layer on a little bit too much,
that stress, that
anxiety, the relationships
that you have.
They can slowly break down.
And if you're not super observant about
how much you are redlining,
they can fully break, the engine can stop.
And so one of the things
that I've learned,
and in some ways you often
learn it through experience,
but hopefully you don't have to learn
it fully through experience,
is yeah, it's fine.
And everyone has a
different redline point.
You know, you gotta challenge yourself.
That's a growth mindset.
Keep challenging yourself,
don't beat up on yourself
if you fail.
And keep challenging yourself.
But if at some point you feel like,
wow, this is starting
to affect my wellbeing,
it's starting to affect my relationships,
I can't handle this level
of intensity for too long.
That's a good sign for you to
take your foot off the pedal.
And in some circles it
can kind of be viewed
as a sign of weakness, that
oh, they're not so intense,
et cetera, et cetera.
But the reality is, anyone who
I've known who's done well,
yes, they might push themselves,
they have a growth mindset,
they're stepping out
of their comfort zone,
they're willing to try things
and fail.
But they have a very good
sense that this is a marathon.
The people who do well aren't the people
who just pull five all-nighters in a row
and then burn out.
They're the people who are able to keep
whatever they're trying to achieve going
for long periods of time.
And that's something I remind myself
and that's what I would
remind to all of y'all.
Figure out what your capacity is,
what you can do, and actually
always leave a little bit
of that margin of safety,
that extra flex space
to recharge.
And then you'll be well
equipped for the marathon,
so to speak.
I have to think, even
in college, I was very,
I probably called myself lazy at the time.
But I did make a point of making sure
that I had time with friends,
that I was getting the
full college experience,
that I wasn't only just trying
to optimize a grade or
something like that.
I'm so glad I did it,
because frankly the things
that I remember from college are much more
of the connections I made,
the conversations I had with friends.
My wife, I met in college.
So that was a great outcome.
And I don't remember a
lot of the classes I took
or whether I got an A
or A- or a B in a class.
So there's definitely,
you need to make space
for all of those aspects of life.
But good question, and it's always good
to call people on whether
they're not being consistent
in their advice with how they live.
So from YouTube, Susana Garcia Dominguez,
Susana I feel like I'm
getting to know you as well.
(laughs) You're asking
a lot of good questions.
In light of these health initiatives,
do you think elementary
school are getting too big?
For example, schools that
are 400 plus students.
So, I'm not sure, I don't know.
I'm not an expert on, I mean,
based on your question,
it sounds like you might
be asking like the epidemiology of it.
And if you put more
than 400 kids in a room,
are they going to be spreading
diseases and whatnot.
I don't know.
I don't know, my intuition there
is it's less about the number,
it's more about how the
school is structured.
But I would say, generally speaking,
it is nice the more attention,
especially young kids can
get, supports from parents,
and students and teachers especially.
So yeah, I could imagine
as classes get too large,
that that can be not ideal
for kid's development
or feeling supported and things like that.
So from YouTube, Miss
Melissa Gaudreau asked,
what is the best way to assess students
during this time of remote learning?
I'm well aware that students cheat.
So it depends what you're
trying to do the assessment for.
We've actually had
conversation at Khan Academy,
and I've had conversations
with other groups
that are trying to
assess student learning.
So Khan Academy is
actually a very good way,
if you wanna just
understand where either you
as the student, where you are,
or if you have a child or you're a teacher
and you have students.
Have them work on the course
challenge on Khan Academy.
Do the unit tests on Khan Academy.
Or just say hey, get as far as you can
in your grade level of
course, or whatever you need
to work on in Khan Academy.
And that level of mastery,
that percent completion that they are,
that's a really good
assessment of where they are
in their learning path.
We've done multiple studies
that show very strong
correlation between progress
on Khan Academy, mastery on Khan Academy,
and other third party
benchmark assessments.
So if you just wanna get a
read of where someone is,
I think you have the tools.
If you want, if you're thinking about
how do I give someone a grade?
Or how do I give them a score
that might impact college admissions
or give them a credential of some kind?
Then the stakes to get higher,
and to your point, there's
some subset of folks
who might be tempted to
cheat in that scenario.
I think there's ways to
minimize that cheating.
Obviously cheating can
happen in any scenario.
When you go to a, there's
classes I remember in college
where you can go to the gym
and there's three hundred
people taking a test,
they never checked our IDs.
So if someone wanted to cheat, they could.
But you often hear they're
really just cheating themselves.
But I think in this online world,
I'm a big believer, actually,
in kind of honor codes.
You tell people, look, sign this document,
vow that you will not cheat.
We have you on video saying that.
And if you cheat, and if it's
discovered you're cheating,
it's proved you're cheating,
the penalties are very high.
So I think that's one way to do it.
Another way is, I think you
could do some light proctoring,
even in the socially distanced world.
Where you say, okay, everyone,
if you wanna get credit for this thing,
maybe you use Khan Academy,
come onto Zoom or Google Meet on this day,
and I will proctor you all.
And I will kind of observe
you as you're taking this.
Now, it's not gonna be
completely foolproof.
There might be, a student
might have a sibling off camera
whispering into their ear or something.
But there's no such thing as foolproof.
You really just wanna get a 99% solution.
And I think, you don't want
perfect to be the enemy of good.
I believe most students
wanna do what's right,
they don't wanna cheat.
And especially even the ones that might
be a little bit more ethically
ambiguous (laughs) about it,
or ambivalent about it.
If you have some penalties if
they're discovered cheating.
We had David Coleman
on about the AP tests,
and I think they're taking that route.
They are taking a lot
of security measures.
But at the end of the day,
if a student is discovered cheating,
plagiarizing, whatever,
there's severe repercussions
for them in life.
And hopefully some of what happened
with the Varsity Blues scandal,
with these college admissions scandals,
its shown people the
downsides of even attempting
to cheat are pretty large.
Ideally your ethics,
yourself, your consciousness,
your conscientiousness
keeps you from cheating.
But if you're afraid of outcomes,
(laughs) then keep in
mind it could be bad.
So, let's see--
- Sal, we have a pretty
good question for you, Sal.
From YouTube, Presheda Jane asks,
Hi Sal, what factors of
ed-tech needs to change
to help in situations like these?
Especially to help kids who
have no access to school?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
The big one, the obvious one is access,
as your question implies.
That's not something
that we at Khan Academy
have been directly been able to do.
Obviously we can't source laptops
and give people free internet access.
It's not what we do.
We are dependent on that somehow existing.
What we've been seeing
because of the COVID crisis,
in schools, especially
in places like the US,
schools have actually
done a really good job
over the last 10 years,
and there have been government
programs like E-Rate,
which have made internet access
and devices much more
common in public schools.
What this crisis highlights
is the inequity at home
is now a major issue.
It's always been an issue, but
this really makes it stark.
And it's not just an
inequity to access something
like Khan Academy, it's also an inequity
in terms of, in this time
of social distancing,
just to stay sane you
wanna be able to connect
with friends and family over a hang out,
over a Zoom session.
And if you don't have internet access,
it's going to be very, very difficult
to just feel connected
to others right now.
We're seeing some really
good programs out there.
One of our guests that we're
gonna have later this week
is Ray Dalio, Ray and Barbara Dalio.
They have sponsored 60,000 laptops
for low income high school
students in Connecticut.
And they're working with
the telecom providers
to get them free internet.
We had Dr. Jesus Jara
on from Clark County,
which is greater Las Vegas,
the 5th largest school district
in the country.
They did a really great job
of first distributing laptops
to their seniors, because those students
that it's most mission critical.
And then they got another 40,000 laptops
that they were able to distribute
to all of the students who needed it.
And they had partnerships
with the local cable companies
to get free internet access.
One of our partners at
Khan Academy, Comcast,
is offering free internet
access to students
for the next, through the crisis.
So the good thing is, a
lot of actors, I believe,
are doing the right thing.
My hope is that this doesn't just happen
through this crisis,
that the crisis is the catalyst
that makes everyone think
very seriously about it.
But then as we exit the
crisis people realize
that it's not a just a
nice to have for students
to have internet access,
or for anyone to have internet access.
It really is approaching
a modern human right,
like clean drinking water or shelter.
And if you get that part solved,
then I think ed-tech goes into,
okay, how do we make sure that students
can stay engaged?
How do we connect what
happens in ed-tech or online
and make sure that it
works and it's integrated
and it's cohesive with what can happen
in the physical environment,
in the physical classroom?
I don't do these things in
tension with each other,
I think online should be
able to seamlessly integrate
in the physical classroom,
but in times of crisis,
you can then lean, like we're
going through right now,
you can lean more heavily on the online.
I think there's interesting
questions like we just had
about how can things
like assessment occur,
credentialing occur online?
Especially when maybe there's
a larger fear of cheating.
How do you connect online experiences
and mastery achieved online
to real opportunities?
So I think all of these
are interesting frontiers.
I'm also fascinated, you know,
we had that earlier question
about apps to create.
I'm fascinated by this
idea of leveraging online.
You know, a lot of Khan Academy right now
you could view as
asynchronous which means,
everyone's learning at
their own time and pace.
But one of the dreams for Khan Academy,
and I wrote this in
"One World Schoolhouse,"
are there ways to connect
people who are willing
to tutor or willing to teach a subject,
and people who need that support?
It's great that we have
videos, it's great that we
have as much practice
and feedback as you need.
It's great that you have
hints and get the solution
of any problem.
But we know that you still might be stuck,
or you still might need
kind of a pick-me-up
or get a little bit motivated.
And it's nothing like an
amazing teacher or tutor
or just someone who cares to help you out
of that moment.
So I would love to leverage.
I'm always fascinated by
how to leverage technology
to actually create more
richness of human interactions.
So let's see, from Facebook,
Kevin Rodriguez asks,
hey Sal, are there any
plans of adding topics
about environmental education, renewables
and climate change or
sustainable development
on Khan Academy?
Many of us in the youth climate movement
would be delighted to help out with that.
Kevin, it's a great
question, and it's a topic
that we've talked about a
lot here at Khan Academy.
You know, one of the
interesting challenges
is there's topics that are very current
and very relevant, but if
we create an amazing course
on that, you know, we would try.
If you don't connect it,
and this goes to the previous answer,
if you don't connect it
somehow to what's going on
through student's
academics, their schools,
credentials, et cetera, it
might not be used by everyone.
And so what we're trying to figure out is,
are there places, say in
science, middle school science
for example, where these
really important ideas
about environmental
science could find a home,
and people can understand
the world through that lens
of critical thinking,
through the lens of science,
I think could be really interesting.
So we actually are, we
have been soliciting
from potential philanthropists
if folks wanted to fund
that type of content.
Middle school level, high
school level, a science.
Amgen has been a great partner of ours
sponsoring content at the high school
and early college level science.
Things like biology and physics.
But we're looking for
partners who can help sponsor
some of that content at that middle school
or even elementary school level as well.
Which I think could touch on a lot of
what you just talked about.
So let's see, from
Facebook Stacy Rosenbaum
asking a similar question,
I'd like to see more science
and social studies on the
elementary end of the spectrum.
We would too, Stacy.
And so the simple answer is,
we're always looking for funding for folks
who might be interested in sponsoring
those types of courses.
So let us know, forward any folks.
And sometimes we dig in
reserves to try to build out
these courses, regardless,
and hope that someone will fund it.
But these are definitely
the types of courses
that we do want to add on Khan Academy.
So let's see, other questions here.
I have a question from
Laura Verdeen on YouTube,
you helped me not only pass,
but do a great job on my
college physics courses.
Oh, that's good to hear, Laura.
How did you learn to
explain concepts so well?
Well, thank you that you found it useful.
You know, what I think,
and I don't know for sure,
if folks are resonating
with content that I
or other team members have created,
I try to think out loud when I do videos.
And I try to be very
transparent with my thoughts.
I mean, even in this
ask-me-anything forum,
hopefully you can tell
I'm being very transparent
with my thoughts.
I'm not being machiavellian,
trying to say,
well, what do people want me to say,
and what is going to be the
most polished professional,
I'm like, yeah, okay Sal,
that's probably the truth,
just share it with folks.
And I try to do the same
thing when I'm teaching
on Khan Academy.
I think a lot of times if
you look at a textbook,
or even sometimes in a lecture,
it all seems scripted and very perfect.
But it's not exactly how people think.
And often times it'll skip steps,
it doesn't connect it to
what you might already know.
And when I try to do
something on Khan Academy,
my brain, while I'm doing the video,
is trying to do all of those things.
And some of those insights
are things that my brain
is just surfacing in real
time, I didn't plan on it.
Just saying, hey, well this
is interesting that entropy
in the computer science
information theory version
is actually mathematically identical
to entropy in the chemistry
kinetic theory ideas.
What is it saying about information?
You know, just trying to
draw these connections
that just might happen in your mind.
And I think, hopefully,
when people listen to that,
they're like oh, this person
is actually here with me.
Even though is it asynchronous,
we're not actually
at the same time with each other.
But you're like, oh, I can
kind of get into the mind.
And I've seen some folks
who are making lessons,
they want it to be so perfect,
they script it out, they skip the steps,
and they sound very
professional, they'll say,
"The next step in this process
is when the mitochondria."
But that's not how we talk in real life.
And when you hear that kind of,
I say, GPS device type talk,
our human brains don't
feel so connected to it.
So I don't know, we don't know
if there is a secret sauce
to Khan Academy, but that's
some of our intuitions,
is that we try to keep it intuitive,
we try to keep it very informal.
When I make content, I
don't view it as I'm someone
who knows knowledge, and you are someone
who does not know knowledge.
I view it as like, hey, we're both people
and we are both equals,
and we have to respect each other.
And I might, right now,
just have a few insights
that you don't have yet.
And so I think whether you're
talking to a five year old
or a 50 year old, to treat people with
that kind of conversational,
don't talk down to them
and also don't talk above them,
I think also might help,
and it de-stresses the interaction.
Anyway, I don't know. (laughs)
We do try to glean some of this.
Because obviously as we grow
in scale and add more content,
we do wanna only get better
at some of these dimensions
for our content.
So it looks like we're all out of time.
This is super.
Actually, I'm gonna
answer one more question,
I just saw this, it
seems really interesting.
Six Just One of Six, and Six,
you've asked several
questions that were very good,
thank you.
What do you think we will
say when you look back
at this time?
And I think that's a great question
to kind of finish today's session,
today's livestream on.
The time we live in, we
don't know how it's going
to play out over the next few months,
is for sure going to be one of those times
that happens every few
decades, that people are going
to be referring to for decades to come.
We are all going to be
telling our children
and other people's children,
and our children's children
about this time.
And our children, who are alive today,
are going to tell their children about it.
And they're going to talk
about how it changed society.
You can go back to some
things like World War One,
the Great Depression, World War Two,
The Cold War, which is kind of
over a longer period of time.
The Vietnam War, things like this.
People all have memories of that
and how it changed
society in certain ways.
9/11 and I'm speaking from a
very kind of American centric
point of view, but you can
imagine in other countries
there were things, traumas,
that their countries went through
that had lasting implications.
Many of them negative, many
of the lasting implications
might have been positive.
It might have been somehow
put systems in place
so that these things
might not happen again.
So I think we will, that
will be a lasting consequence
in terms of what are those changes?
I've talked about this
in other livestreams,
I think it's making all of
us appreciate the things
that really matter more.
You know, we all get caught
up in the rat race of like,
oh, I need to get into this
college and get that grade,
and get this job, and
then I need this title
and I need that office and
I need that type of car.
And I could use a little
bit more square footage
in my house.
So then people will think
that I've really succeeded
and I can dress a little better.
And whether we admit it or not,
all of us, to some degree,
get a little bit caught up in that.
Some of us, to a large
degree, get caught up in that.
And I think when
everything just comes down
to your health, how do
you protect your family,
how do you protect society?
There's people who've lost their jobs,
they don't know how they're
going to buy food next week.
It all, I think it's
sobering and can be sobering
in a healthy way that makes you realize
that that's what's important.
The connections with family
and friends, your health,
that's what's important.
There's no reason to stress yourself out
and give yourself a heart attack
over getting a corner office
or getting into a certain school,
when that thing matters way
less than your heart health.
So if I think there's a silver lining
that comes out of this,
it re-grounds all of us
on what really matters in life.
Staying connected and learning.
And appreciating what it means to be alive
and be a human being.
So with that, I'll let everyone go.
I'll see you all tomorrow.
Tomorrow we will have a great guest
from The College Board
to talk about the SAT.
And I look forward to seeing you tomorrow
and future days.